(cheerful music)
- I'd like to tell you
about some of the processes
that unfold as the baby
brain grows and develops,
in particular I'm gonna focus on
the underpinnings of language,
since language learning
impairment is a feature
of so many developmental disorders,
which we're gonna get into later.
So why look at baby brain function?
Because while we watch
this magical unfolding
of early abilities across development,
we can begin to answer
some very big questions,
including how do early
events of development
influence later cognition
and later competence?
What risk factors during early development
have consequences for
adult behavior or disorder
and how that might, how
might that be altered,
and how can very early
abnormalities in the functional
organization of brain networks be causal
in developmental disorders,
such as language learning
disorder, autism, or ADHD.
And importantly, how early
might biomarkers be detected,
measured and perhaps
remediated with non-invasive
technologies?
So as newborns, babies can
discriminate the sounds
of every language acoustically
but not linguistically.
So starting at birth, the
baby's developing brain
is constructing an
acoustic map of the sounds
of his or her native language.
And this gradual process,
perceptual narrowing,
is thought to be completed
by the end of the first year.
Mapping of these acoustic
contrasts is important
because their salient to
the surrounding language
ultimately allows the
child to respond in a
fast automatic way to the
incoming language stream,
and it's problematic if
this doesn't go well.
Because it impacts mounting
of fluent native language
as well as cognition and later reading
due to difficulties in what's called
phoneme to grapheme mapping,
that is matching speech sounds to lens
which you need to do to read.
Efficient processing of
basic auditory events
in the 10s of millisecond domain,
called rapid auditory processing,
is critical to mounting language
in normative development,
and allows the most optimal acoustic maps
to be constructed.
And this is because many speech sounds,
phonemes like "da" or "ta"
only differ by brief spectral
and or temporal changes
specifically within
the 10s of milliseconds.
And differences in these basic
acoustic processing abilities
have been shown to be
related to both concurrent
and later language learning difficulties.
Research from my lab strongly suggests
that the ability to
perform these very fine
acoustic discriminations
within speech or non-speech,
because we mainly look at
pre-linguistic non-speech,
is critically important
to normative language
and it may go awry in a subset
of developmental disorders.
Moreover, these skills
predict language outcomes
through early pre-reading
and have an impact
on later learning.
So many of our studies,
we examine populations at higher risk
for various disorders as
a consequence of a child
being born into a family
with such disorders.
And heritability to study suggest
the risk can be 30 to 60% higher,
depending on which
disorder and which study.
So how do you measure
brain responses in infants?
You can use eletroencephalography, EEG,
which reflects the summation of
the synchronous activity
of millions of neurons
that have similar spatial orientation.
You can also use brain
invoked related potentials.
And this is an average across many trials
to generate an average
wave-form that is timelocked
to external stimulation.
This permits examination
of the time course
in the brain areas related
to sensory processing,
and you can compare and
contrast group response
as well as compare individual
responses to group norms.
Research suggests that brain oscillations,
which are cyclic fluctuations
of the membrane potential
in brain cells control
neuronal excitability,
integrate sensory inputs
and may coordinate higher-level functions
such as language, memory and learning.
However, neural dynamics whose
just beginning to be studied
in the human infant, our
previous studies in pilot data
strongly suggest that oscillatory dynamics
and their hierarchical organization
have a developmental timeline
and may capture disruption
in normative development.
So how can you look at that?
You can look at the EEG.
And you can do something called
a fast foraying analysis,
this is one way of doing it,
which breaks the EEG pattern down
into its component frequencies.
Synchronized neural oscillations
in these low frequencies,
Delta, Theta and Alpha
are thought to provide
key mechanisms that orchestrate
network coordination
during development, and may
be involved in information
transfer among brain areas.
Theta oscillations in particular
are important for perceptual
and cognitive functions,
such as declarative and episodic memory,
and have been proposed
as a neural mechanism
subserving phonemic discrimination,
which is one of the reasons
we're very interested in it.
Gamma oscillations from
30 to 80 or 90 Hertz
may represent synchronized activity
of local neuronal populations
during sensory and cognitive processes,
but may also, particularly high Gamma,
play a role in coupling
of remote cortical areas.
So given that activity
in this Gamma frequency
has been linked in humans and animals
to a wide variety of
higher cognitive processes,
including attention, memory and language,
we first examined power
density in frontal cortex
across the language burst
in two groups of children.
And I'm gonna give you
a few little snippets
of some studies.
We studied the power of spectra
in two groups of children
with and without a family history
of language learning impairment,
at 16, 24 and 36 months of age,
when this huge burst in language occurs.
We found that individual
differences in frontal gamma power
during rest highly correlated
with concurrent language
and cognitive skills at all ages.
Children with a family history
of language learning impairment
had lower frontal gamma at all ages.
Power was also associated
with attentional measures,
children who were observed as having
better inhibitory control
and more mature attention
shifting abilities
had higher power.
We continued to follow this group
and we found that examining gamma across
the language burst strongly predicted
to both cognition and language
at ages four and five years.
We saw that at 16, 24 and 36 months,
resting gamma was
associated with four year
language comprehension scores
and word structure and
sentence structure scores.
And at 24 and 36 months,
gamma power was significantly associated
with five-year sentence imitation,
which is really important for pre-readers,
36-month gamma power was
also significantly associated
with five-year syntactical skills.
So what's the take-home message here?
We believe that the capacity
to generate higher power
in the gamma range at these
crucial developmental periods
may index better modulation of attention
and allow easier access to working memory,
providing an advantage
for overall development,
particularly in the linguistic domain.
We were then interested in examining
oscillatory support in younger infants,
so using event-related
potential, source localization
and a time-frequency analysis
of event-related oscillations,
so from source, we examined
the neural substrates
of rapid auditory processing
in four-month-olds.
Animal models and adult experiments
suggest that oscillatory synchrony,
and in particular
low-frequency oscillations
in the delta and theta range,
play key roles in rapid
auditory processing
and auditory change detection.
So we hypothesized that
synchronized activity
in brain oscillations in left and right
auditory cortices would support
rapid frequency discrimination in infants.
Moreover, we thought that
infant perception of rapid pitch
and timing changes, which is so critical,
should be mediated in part at least
by oscillatory mechanisms.
These issues had not been
looked at in infants at all
in human infants.
We used two sets of stimuli,
speech-like tones (beeping),
and a control condition
that was out of the speech-like range.
So we found, this is a very busy slide,
but I'll walk you through it.
You're gonna see some of these figures
that show pooled
oscillatory power over time,
with frequency on the
x-axis, time on the y-axis
for these complex tone
pairs in the control rate
and in the rapid rate,
the speech-like rate.
And these are for standards,
the background sounds,
these are deviants, the ones that change,
and this is the difference
between the two.
Base synchronization is in red,
desynchronization is in blue.
And what we saw was that there
was enhanced phase-locking
to variant tones in both rate conditions.
Larger and faster activation
in the right hemisphere
at both rates.
However, left auditory
activity was enhanced
only during Rapid Rate presentation.
We also gave these babies
a go/no-go behavioral task
at their second visit.
Auditory perception was
measured by the infant's ability
to learn a reward contingency
for a deviant tone in a pair,
and the number of trials it took the baby
to get four out of five
correct was their criterion.
And we did a median split with
faster and slower learners
and what you see is
that tone discrimination
is strongest for the
children who learn faster.
We also saw that slower learners
had smaller power differences
between their standard
and deviant responses.
And this is, suggests that
they had a lot of difficulty
discriminating one signal from another.
So the take away message here is that
local low frequency oscillatory synchrony
underlies rapid processing
and can robustly index
auditory abilities in young infants.
And recruitment of the left hemisphere
during rapid frequency change
suggests a difference in the
spectral and temporal resolution
of the right and left hemispheres,
even at this very early age.
Moreover, we were able to predict behavior
in a go/no-go task by looking
at oscillatory brain power.
So the question is if we can find deficits
so early in life, can we alter them
using the exquisite plasticity typical
of this early developmental time period,
while infants are setting
up their acoustic mapping?
Can we make the baby a better processor
and can we see
intervention-specific changes
in the brain waves and
oscillatory patterns
that reflect enhanced processing?
So can we look for some causal mechanisms?
And so we did a study, we
did a couple of studies,
and looking at plasticity
in developing brain
and seeing if active auditory exposure
would impact prelinguistic
acoustic mapping.
And I'm gonna go through
this pretty quickly,
but the paper's published if you need it.
So we looked at the neural
correlates of acoustic mapping
with dense array EEG/ERP before and after
a six-week interactive,
progressive acoustic experience.
We used a operantly-conditioned
go/no-go active paradigm
with an eye-tracking control,
so the baby could actually
manipulate the experiment.
And we used a passive control
and a naive maturation control.
And here's the study design,
two longitudinal arms,
one with active training,
one with passive training,
and two, a cross-sectional sample
of children who were not trained.
So what did they get
when they were trained?
Once a week for six weeks,
for six to eight minutes,
the babies were trained
on three different types
of paired stimuli, complex
tones, bandpass noise,
frequency sweeps presented at varying ISIs
and varying complexities,
using an up-down staircase procedure.
So if the baby got it
right, it got harder,
they got it wrong, it got easier,
and so they went up and down
until they reached criterion.
The passive group got the same stimuli
and the same time exposure,
but passive with no feedback,
and we didn't train the naive children.
After they were trained,
we collected data on ERPs, EEGs
that they had been trained on,
as well as different types
of generalization stimuli,
so we looked at deviants with
spectral temporal parameters
that significantly differed
from the training stimuli,
one with the gap, one with
the differing duration,
and one with frequency.
So what did we see?
Yes this is a monster figure,
so we're not gonna talk about
the grand average wave-forms,
I'm gonna just pull out the information
about these time-locked
age appropriate topograms
to first of all, this P2 peak.
And this is a peak that happens
that's an attentional peak.
And what we see here is
around each topogram,
if it has a red box, it
means there was significantly
faster latencies.
So the active group was
significantly faster
than both the passive and the
naive groups on this peak.
And then we also were
interested in looking at
what's called the N2 star.
And this is the change discrimination peak
that happens right before
the baby discriminates
the signal.
And it's important because
it's been shown to be
a robust infant predictor
of later language.
So both of the auditory
groups, experienced groups,
were significantly faster
than the naive controls,
but the actives had a larger amplitude
compared to both other groups
and showed a left
hemisphere lateralization.
We then looked at the signals that were
generalization stimuli,
and what you can see in these bar graphs
is mean latency of each deviant
at each of the nine electrode sites.
For P1, that's the first
sensory peak that signals
that a stimulus has been perceived.
And what you can see here for the gap,
for the duration and the frequency is,
the active group was significantly faster
at all nine electrode sites.
So we demonstrated that
while both active and passive
acoustic experience from
four to seven months
modulated non-speech stimuli,
active experience conferred
a significant advantage,
that active experience increased attention
to environmental acoustic stimuli,
and that faster latencies were seen
for the change discrimination peak
that has been shown to be
a robust infant predictor
of later language.
Moreover, we saw a
generalization to both trained
and untrained stimuli
over and above that seen
for maturation alone.
And do these intervention
effects generalize to language?
I can just say yes because I think
we're just about at the end,
but just let me show you this high gamma
at nine months, we can
look at them longitudinally
and you can see that for the actives,
you have this very high gamma input here,
which is a prominent characteristic
of early sensory processing
and may index cortical activation,
given larger high but
not low gamma responses
are correlated with increases
in overall firing rates,
particularly during
attentional modulation.
And with that, I'll show you our prototype
that does the same intervention
in the baby's home.
And that's the end.
(applauding)
- So yeah, I wanna, I
really wanna follow on
in this wonderful vein
of discussion and thought
that we've had so far this, today.
Thinking about this question,
making an brain young,
as I get older, I want to be younger.
So this is part of it, but
I really wanna consider
how we can take lessons from understanding
the child's brain and
see if we can apply them
to the adult brain or the aging brain
or the neural, the brain
with neuralpathology.
And so first before I actually do that,
I really wanna talk about
the concept of what a critical period is,
and just remind you that
a developmental critical period
is a period during which time
its special experiences are essential
for the later functioning of the brain,
and that's because these
experiences are essential
for tuning up brain circuits,
and I wanna talk about that in
much more detail in a minute,
but a good example of a
developmental critical period
that I've experienced alas myself
is one for language learning.
Obviously you can learn throughout life,
you can learn languages
just throughout life.
But learning a language
without an accent as an adult
is extremely difficult,
whereas we all know now,
it's extremely easy to learn
many languages perfectly
as a young child.
And this has been my regret my whole life.
Now how, so here's the concept, basically,
which is if we could only understand
the underlying molecular
and cellular mechanisms
that regulate these
developmental critical periods,
maybe we could then apply them.
Either in aid of repair,
to reverse developmental neuropathology,
or maybe even as a cognitive enhancer,
so I could learn French for
example without an accent.
Now in trying to
understand how this works,
obviously at the level
of molecules and cells
we really need to get into the brain,
and it's possible to
do this in mice models.
And in fact, mice as far as I know,
have not been learning
second or third languages.
But mice, just like us,
have binocular vision.
So here's the question.
Have you ever thought about
why it is you don't see double?
I mean, what's happening
right is you have two eyes
and each eye is sending a
complete view of the visual world
to your brain, and yet, we
only see one view of the world
unless there's some pathology.
And one of the reasons
that we don't see double
is because in fact, the
neuro circuitry for vision
brings the connections
from the two eyes together
in the central part of
the visual pathways.
And let me just show you
a very simplified diagram
of that now.
So the point is, that the
output neurons from the eyes,
these RGCs, the ganglion cells,
send their connections to
central structures, like the LGN
and then beyond that from the LGN
to the primary visual cortex,
so vision doesn't happen,
visual perception doesn't happen
in your eye, it happens in your brain.
And so these first few
steps you can see already
how the wiring is bringing
the two eyes together.
So for example, one of these RGCs here
is sending its connection
across to this LGN,
another one from the other
eye is sending its connection,
and already you can see
that the information
from the two eyes is
beginning to be combined,
and then at the next stage
in information processing,
that information is
again even more combined,
in fact there's a rather
beautiful, in this case,
left eye, right eye, left eye, right eye,
left eye, right eye kind of
intermixing of the inputs
from the two eyes and actually
those intermixed inputs
make connections finally with
these little gray circles
and these connections
are the target neurons
that fall off, become the basis
for your binocular vision,
in other words they're getting input
from both the right eye and the left eye.
Now before I go further, I
wanna define more what I mean
about connections, I'm
talking about connections,
but what I really mean
in neuroscience terms
is synapses, the synapse,
what is a synapse,
so let me just define a synapse.
A synapse is the junction or connection
between one neuron and the
next neuron along the line,
passing information and by the way
also doing some computations
as the information is passed.
And in fact, you are your synapses.
What I mean by that is
your synapses get tuned up
during developmental critical periods,
and even if you are genetically
identical to your sister,
your twin or whatever, in fact,
your brain synapses are different
because the pattern of
tuning is slightly different
in each case.
So you are your synapses.
Synapses change with learning.
Memories are stored at synapses.
And sadly, in Alzheimer's
disease, synapses are lost,
and so let's just remember
that as I talk further.
Now what's amazing is that
in animal models, it's
possible to visualize synapses.
So we can go down to the
level of just a few microns
and actually see and test synapses
and understand how they
work in the animal models,
like in the mice or
even in higher mammals.
And many years ago this
experiment was done,
and it's actually possible to visualize
this really beautiful left eye, right eye,
left eye, right eye, left
eye, right eye pattern
of synapses in the visual cortex,
and I just wanna show you
a very famous picture now
from David Hubel and Torsten Wiesel's lab.
And at this scale, let me just point out
that these white blobs
over here on the left are,
they're supposed to be grains of rice,
so this gives you some sense of scale,
those are grains of rice,
and here you see one eye,
let's say the right eye,
was labeled with a white tracer substance
that gets all the way to the visual cortex
and labels all the synapses
that are functionally connected
to the white right eye.
And so you can see, what I
told you that there's this
beautiful right eye, left
eye, right eye, left eye,
right eye, left eye striping pattern.
And at this scale, what
you're looking at really is
hundreds of thousands of
these synapses at this scale,
where every little dot is
about the size of a synapse.
Now when neuroscientists first discovered
this beautiful striping pattern
of synaptic connections,
they thought it had to be hard-wired,
it's much too beautiful,
much too reproducible
to be left to chance.
But in fact it turns out
that during post-natal,
critical period of development,
this pattern has to be
tuned up, in other words,
even using both eyes
together for binocular vision
requires an experienced dependent period.
And in fact, one way
that this was discovered
is in trying to understand
what's different between
childhood cataract
and cataract that you
might get as an adult,
or your grandmother might get as an adult,
where if you have normal
vision your whole life,
and then you lose vision in one
eye for some period of time,
when the optics are corrected,
then you can see again
perfectly as an adult,
and that's because these
beautiful stripes are stable.
However, during a developmental period,
these stripes are not stable,
they're getting tuned up.
And if a child has a congenital cataract
that's not corrected
early on in development,
then the eye that's good gets way more
than its fair share of territory,
so way more white synapses
in the visual cortex
than the bad eye gets.
And the bad eye actually
loses synaptic connections,
in fact those connections are pruned
and Jay referred to this, I
think several of our previous
speakers talked about
this idea of a period
when there's a lot of synaptic remodeling
and pruning going on.
And that's what I wanna
really talk about now.
So let me just summarize by saying,
what you see now before your
eyes is a really beautiful
example of synaptic plasticity, that is
the ability of a neural
circuit to change its pattern
of connections based on use.
And this is an experience
dependent change,
and in this case, it happens
only during a developmental
critical period in the sense that
after the critical period is over,
which in us is around the age of six,
these connections become stable
and they can't change this
dramatically at later ages
which is why grandma can see
even after having a cataract
for a long period of
time, whereas the child,
if the cataract isn't fixed quite soon,
will be permanently blind in
the eye that was not used.
So this is a real use it
or lose it kind of thing.
So let me just summarize
here again by saying then
that the baby's brain, just
like the adolescence brain,
is not a miniature version
of the adult brain.
It's a dynamically changing structure.
And part of the change that's happening,
and we can see it in the animal models,
like mice for example,
is that there's this
synaptic remodeling,
so synaptic plasticity
is the basis for these
developmental critical periods,
and during this time,
many immature synapses,
the ones that are used
get strengthened and stabilized,
and the ones that are not are pruned away.
So there's a kind of pruning
versus a growth period.
So now, the question is, how
in the world does this work?
How is this happening and if
we could only understand it,
we could restore plasticity
maybe to the adult brain,
but in order to do it,
really have to understand
what are the underlying
molecules and mechanisms
that actually are
responsible for this kind of
pruning process.
So for many, many years
ago, we worked very hard
to discover molecules that
might be involved in pruning.
And I wanna tell you about one.
So this molecule is a big mouthful.
It's called PirB.
It's called paired
immunoglobulin-like receptor B.
And it's very cool that it's a receptor.
The reason I emphasize that is because
if you have a receptor, it
can be targeted for a drug
or a pill, as I said
this is like my dream,
but we're not there yet, but
it's good that it's a receptor.
And the question is, how can
we show that this molecule
is actually involved in plasticity?
So one way that it's
possible in a mouse anyhow,
is, well first of all I
should say that this molecule
is present in the brain,
it's in the neurons,
happily it's in our
favorite parts of the brain
that we like to study all the time.
The visual cortex in the mouse
and the hippocampus in the mouse.
So it's there.
Now how can we actually
study its function?
Well in mice,
it's possible to remove
that particular molecule
by taking away just that gene
from the whole genome of the mouse,
so there're 30,000 genes or so,
and one can remove just that gene
and from the very beginning
of development for instance,
so we can make what's known
as a PirB gene knockout.
And we can then either remove the gene
from the very beginning of development,
or if we're really fancy we
can take it away at any time
of life and then we can
test is this gene needed
for whatever, synaptic plasticity.
And the bottom line
is, what we discovered,
is that in fact, in these gene knockouts,
in fact there is not
always the gene needed,
but there's actually
more synaptic plasticity
than normal, and I'm happy
to talk about this later,
but just take my word for it,
PirB is needed for synaptic plasticity.
And so then we asked
how is this happening,
what is actually going on?
And you already know the
answer because I told you.
I told you that during
that synaptic plasticity
involves both pruning and strengthening
of certain connections.
So we thought let's look
at pruning in these PirB
knockout mice.
And to make a long story
short, what we discovered
is that pruning is deficient.
And the way we did this experiment
was to label some of our
favorite neurons in the brain,
these little green dots,
with a green tracer substance.
And then we could actually look at
very high power over here.
We could look at these
little protuberances,
which are the sites of the synaptic inputs
to these particular neurons,
and then we could count them all.
And when we did that
experiment in normal, wild-type
versus PirB knockout mice,
what we discovered is
that there were actually
way more of these connections
in the knockout mice
than in the wild-type mice,
and that actually persisted
all the way into adulthood.
And what we'd actually discovered is that
somehow PirB is required
for synaptic pruning.
And in the absence of PirB,
so in this knockout mouse,
what we discovered is that
pruning was deficient,
the see-saw went in favor
of synapse formation,
genesis and stabilization, and
away from synaptic pruning.
Okay now there's a lot more
one could say about this
but actually what I
really wanna talk about is
boing, a light bulb went off for us,
actually a few light
bulbs went off for us,
but I wanna tell you about one.
Here's the light bulb.
The light bulb is that
in Alzheimer's disease,
there's excessive synapse pruning.
And this is thought to be
caused at least in part
by these bad plaques and tangles
that are formed by the
accumulation of a substance called
Beta amyloid, which actually conglomerates
to make very large plaques and tangles.
And it's thought that this Beta amyloid
is part of what's responsible
for loss of memory
in Alzheimer's disease.
So question is, is PirB involved
because remember PirB is
pruning is needed pruning
and here we have too much
pruning in Alzheimer's disease.
So how would you study that?
Well we studied it in a large
variety of different ways,
but the first way is PirB knockout mice,
please meet Alzheimer's disease mice,
so what do I mean by that?
So neuroscientists can make
mouse models of disease,
and what they can do is they
can actually put into the mouse
the human disease gene, the mutated gene,
and sadly for the mice,
but thank you mice,
the mice can then end
up with a human disease.
And in the case Alzheimer's mice,
there are a variety of models,
but in this case there are two genes
that are known to cause early
onset family Alzheimer's.
Both of these are put into the mouse,
and the mouse, at about
nine months of age,
gets the plaques and
tangles, and sadly also
a serious memory loss.
So what we did is we decided,
let's see what happens if we removed PirB.
Remember, if we remove PirB,
then there's no pruning that happens.
So what happens in Alzheimer's
mice that don't have PirB,
and amazingly when we studied
their memory performance
at nine months of age, they were protected
from memory loss in the
absence of the PirB molecule,
so that actually kinda makes sense,
it's rather exciting
at least to me, it is.
So how does this happen?
So again to make another
really long story short,
what we discovered is this PirB receptor
is actually hijacked by this Beta amyloid,
and what do I mean by hijacked?
What I mean is, that PirB
as I said is a receptor,
which always gets everybody excited
in terms of making drugs.
A receptor is a protein on a cell
that does work for the cell.
It takes information
from outside of the cell
and it actually transfers that information
to inside of the cell,
where it can do work.
And in the case of PirB,
that information is part
of the pruning process.
And there are normal ligands for PirB,
including this thing called MHC Class One.
So what we think is happening
is that Beta amyloid
is also binding to this PirB molecule
and driving pruning to excess.
So the other point I wanna make
is that it turns out that
there are actually human
homologues of PirB, there
are quite a number of them,
and what we discovered
is that one of them,
called another mouthful,
I'm not even gonna write it out for you,
it's called LilrB2, so
it's very similar to PirB,
and this human homologue is also binds,
it seems to be hijacked by
the PirB, by Beta amyloid,
and it's also present
in the human forebrain
and the signaling caused
by binding of Beta amyloid
seems to be also derailed in the same way
the human Alzheimer brain
as it is in the mouse brain.
Okay so now I'm gonna summarize.
Okay so what I've suggested
is that Alzheimer's disease,
which is thought to be a
problem of synapse pruning
may be driven by Beta
amyloid-PirB interactions,
definitely worth following that up.
So pruning is accelerated in this case,
and what it also suggests to us
is there might a pill in there after all.
And what's great is that we
could even maybe make a pill
based on the fact that
there's a receptor here,
we know exactly what to do, and in fact,
we have made a little pill
and tried it out in mice
and so the last point I
wanna make is stay tuned.
So I think it's really interesting
that PirB or LilrB
blockade might represent
a slightly different therapeutic approach
for treating Alzheimer's,
but maybe also other pruning disorders.
Now this might be good in the sense that
I don't know if you read recently,
but there was another
failure of another major
Lilly Alzheimer disease drug trial,
so it's really, I'm getting older,
I would really like something soon.
I want these trials to succeed.
But maybe there's a pill,
but even more interesting I think is
that in fact lessons from
neural development may offer
new treatment avenues
for Alzheimer's disease
and other pruning disorders.
So with that I just wanna thank everyone.
Thank you all, and also I
wanna thank our organizers
and I have to remind
everyone that this experiment
was done, these kinds of experiments,
with many many students and
colleagues, and someone,
and I would also like to thank the mice.
So thanks everyone.
- What I'm gonna try to do is to
tell you what the challenge
is and how far we've gotten.
So first of all, this diagram
which Pat Churchill and I
first published in our book in 1992,
The Computational Brain,
illustrates the real difficulty here of,
because there's 11 orders
of spatial magnitude
between molecules down
here at the very bottom
and the entire central nervous system
that gives rise to
behavior at the very top.
At the meter scale.
And we've heard talks today
at every one of these levels.
We've heard about hormones,
the important impact
that they have on remodeling the brain,
especially during adolescence.
Synapses, we've heard that pruning
may be of critical importance,
both in the development
and the generation.
So that's clearly very
important and understanding
how the molecules at the
synapses in particular
are responsible for maturation
is going to be critical.
We know that there are
changes occurring in networks,
for example, we heard
about the impact of sound
on the maturation of a
baby's auditory system
and how important that was
for being able to later
have normal language and learning ability.
If you can't hear properly,
then it's very difficult
to know what people are saying,
and especially if you
start going to school,
it puts you at a great disadvantage.
We heard about the brain imaging,
the important technique
that allows us to tap into
large scale patterns of brain activity.
But how do you jump from
these large scale patterns
way up here, global activity,
down all the way through all
the systems and the maps.
We heard about the visual system,
it's a sequence of maps
from primary visual cortex
to dozens, up to the very higher areas
that are responsible for being
able to recognize objects.
How are we gonna connect the
dots between all these areas,
that's really the challenge.
And it's not gonna be necessarily
jumping from molecules to CNS,
although we'd always like
the magic pill right?
That is targeting a specific molecule
and then hoping that that will solve,
I don't think that's a good a model,
the fact that we've had
how many clinical trials
for Alzheimer's that
have failed in the last
two or three years, it's
at least a dozen trials
saying that amyloid plaque is by itself,
is getting rid of it
isn't necessarily the way
to solve the problem.
Now there's something missing from this
and I had to say that there's
a lot missing from it.
But just from today's
talks, I think you've heard
that we have to add at
least one more type of cell
to this diagram.
That half the cells in
your brain are glial cells.
And in particular, there's the astrocytes,
you're heard a lot about the microglia,
the oligdendrocytes are very important too
because they're the ones
that wrap around the axons
and they speed the action
potential down the axon.
That has to do with timing.
And so we really have to
put that front and center
if we're gonna especially understand
something about when things go wrong.
Now,
when I was young,
I was told that space
is the final frontier
from watching Star Trek.
(laughing)
But I've now come to believe that
the final frontier is going to be time.
Understanding how the temporal processing
occurring in different
circuits and delays that occur
between communication, between
different parts of the brain
may be critically important
and we've neglected it.
So I've worked on networks
for my entire career.
And I've always thought of networks
as being the tightly
interconnected group of neurons
typically in the cortex,
a single neuron connecting
to 10,000 neighbors,
and in a single column 100,000 neurons
and that adds up to
at the end, billions of
synapses in a single column.
But there's another kind of network,
and that's a communication network.
A communication network
is the one that extends,
broadcasts the signals in
your cell phones, right,
they're being broadcast through
a communication network.
And the brain has one that
is just as sophisticated
as anything that we've ever come across.
But I want to take you
back to the early days
when Carla was a young puppy.
And, or a young kitten I guess,
I'm not sure what (laughs)
would be the proper way of putting it.
When she made a very important (laughs)
sorry Carla (laughing).
It was a very important observation about
traveling waves in the retina,
the reason why it's
important is that these occur
even before the eye opens.
So those dynamic patterns
of activity that are
already spreading through the retina.
And here you can see,
this is now from a more recent paper,
but this is from an array of
electrodes that are put on
the retina, that's slapped down
and these are the action potentials
coming from the ganglion cells.
And you can see over seconds,
this wave of activity
sweeps across the retina,
now why is that interesting,
well it turns out that this,
these waves are giving
a temporal structure
to the action potentials
going up to the next stage
in the lateral geniculate,
and it's essential for
getting that pathway
wired up properly.
Being able to sort out the
input from the two eyes,
first of all, 'cause the
waves are independent,
but secondly there's
information about location
because as the waves spreads
from one location to the next,
the action potentials arrive
one position to the next
and that helps sort out the map in LGN
and ultimately into the cortex.
Now very recently we discovered
waves in the cerebral cortex.
Global waves.
Unbelievably large scale
patterns of activity
that we still don't understand
the significance of,
although I have a pretty good hypothesis.
And they occur while you are sleeping.
When you go to sleep, you
go through several stages
from awake down to deep slow wave sleep,
but on the way you go through stage two,
what's called intermediate sleep,
and it's characterized
by these sleep spindles.
These are bursting activity
that originates in the thalamus,
projects to the cortex.
They are 10 to 14 Hertz,
they last one or two seconds,
they recur every five seconds,
and there are some people who spend
up to half of the night
in this slow wave sleep,
during which the spindles are occurring.
Now I've done some very
detailed biophysical modeling,
so I can tell you precise mechanisms
that give rise to the
spindles, it's a bursting,
it has to do with new ion
channels that are uncovered
when the cells hyperpolarize,
it means the membrane potential goes down.
But what I would have never guessed
is how the activity between
the thalamus and the cortex
organizes itself, in the
textbooks what you hear is
that it's synchronous,
that is to say it occurs
at the same place in the cortex
at exactly the same time.
And it is approximately synchronous.
But I wanted to let
you decide for yourself
how synchronous it really is.
So this is an array of
electrodes, eight by eight
64 electrodes that have
been placed on a surface
of the cortex in an epilepsy patient,
who has been, gone to the hospital with
a form of epilepsy that can't
be treated with any drugs.
And so what they have to
do is isolate the focus
so they can go in and
take it out and hopefully
keep that epilepsy, the person,
from having seizures again.
So here's the electrodes,
and by the way they have
these electrodes in for about a week,
waiting for a seizure to occur,
so it's a fantastic opportunity
for someone like me,
a neuroscientist who wants
to ask fundamental questions
about a human brain.
About things like language,
for which there was
no other model system.
Okay so what we've done
is color each in gray
from white to black.
As you can see, the amplitude.
And this is the one that
you're gonna see here in red
is this one, but all the other electrodes
are gonna be represented that way.
And I want you just to
follow the white dots.
And tell me what pattern they form.
This is going around one
77 milliseconds right,
so this is going around
at roughly 14 Hertz.
And you can see as it goes up and down,
so did everybody see what I saw?
It's a rotating circular traveling wave.
And it's global.
It goes from, as you can see,
it goes form the temporal
cortex to the parietal cortex
up to the prefrontal cortex.
And if you look at the pattern
on the side of my head,
this should remind you of Princess Leia.
(laughing)
Now what are these...
So this of course occurs
thousands of times
during the night, what are they doing?
We think it has something to
do with synaptic plasticity.
Because the timing is just
right for something called
spike time dependent plasticity.
And so it may be that
we know there's replay
from the hippocampus during the night.
It's called memory consolidation
and it occurs over many many nights
and this might be the mechanism.
So we have a really great opportunity here
to actually explore it.
Now we know that there are connections,
long range connections
between different parts
of the cortex, these are
called association fibers,
and also across between the hemispheres.
And it's really these
that we think are carrying
the time delay signals,
and it may be that these
time delays are really
important to getting them right.
We know that for example
in traumatic brain injury
when soldiers come back
from the Middle East
with traumatic, problems with trauma,
they often have problems
with concentration
and attention, and concussions
on football players
and so forth, and when you
look in the brain with MR,
the only thing you can find
are little spots of the white matter,
so it could well be that the white matter
is really important for
integrating globally
all the information,
different parts of the cortex,
and it could be that by
strengthening connections
between these distant
areas through spindles
or some other mechanism
that we're able to connect
up all the different parts
of the sensory cortices and association
in the prefrontal cortex.
Now the timing is also
obviously very important
in the auditory cortex
and the motor systems,
so this is I think something
it hasn't been explored,
we focus so much on the gray matter
and not so much on the white matter.
There are some really
intriguing observations
that when learning takes place,
it's not just the synapses
that change their strength,
the volume of the white matter changes.
How could that be?
Well the oligdendrocytes
that wrap around the axons
change the speed, so
maybe what's happening
is you're adjusting
the timing of the spike
as it goes across these
large scale connections
between two different parts of the cortex.
That's all speculative but
I think it really means
we have to start looking
carefully at the axons
as well as the dendrites.
Now I'm gonna play a science
fiction movie for you.
It's an animated, but it's
based on the connections we see
and it's also, it gives you,
you'll see an impression
of the activity that might be taking place
within the cortex.
So these little white flashes
are actually action potentials, spikes,
going down the axons that you just saw
between these different cortical areas.
And this gives you an
impression of what it might be
if you could actually see into your brain.
You know, the person sitting next to you,
and actually see what they're thinking.
Or what they're seeing, or
what it is that they're doing
in terms of their motor
system, every single thought
is gonna be represented by
some pattern of activity
in some part of your
brain, and specifically
in different parts of the cortex.
Now, right now, this is
science fiction for the human,
but, on April 2nd 2013,
Obama announced this grand initiative,
this only, these grand
initiatives only occur
once every decade or two.
And when they do, it really has an impact.
And it has had a huge impact
in the neuroscience community
over the last three years.
The key letters by the
way in the acronym, IN,
is innovative neurotechnology.
And I have to say that our
sponsors, the Kavli Foundation,
were critically important
in bringing this opportunity
to the notice of the White House,
and Miyoung Chung in
particular was the spark plug
who actually got the thing off the ground,
so we really owe the Kavli Foundation
a great debt of gratitude.
But what's happened
since this announcement
is really astonishing because
new tools and techniques
are coming online that
are accelerating research
by orders of magnitude, and
let me give you one example.
And this is not science fiction.
This is real.
This, you are seeing a zebra
fish in a larval brain.
You can see it's not, it's
only a millimeter or so across.
Contains about 80,000 neurons.
It has a genetic marker that
will light the neuron up
when it's activated,
see here's the neuron,
here's the neuron, these
are the ones that are firing
at this particular moment in time.
And this is looking at it
from below, from above,
from the front and from the side.
We can record from all the
neurons at the same time
from this brain, okay?
And I'm gonna play a
movie just to prove that.
Now I have to tell you
this zebra fish larva
is just sitting there, it's immobilized.
And there's no sensory
input, there's no light.
So what you're seeing is
called spontaneous activity.
But every once in a while,
the spontaneous activity,
the pattern changes like
right there, what's happening?
Something happened in the
brain of the zebra fish
that is unrelated to
anything that the zebra fish
is experiencing or is actually moving.
But it's really clear,
to me at least, that we don't
understand the first thing.
(laughing)
And as a Chinese curse, may
you get what you wish for,
and this is something we've always wanted
to be able to have access
to all of the neurons
and the activity occurring,
I mean for all we know, the zebra fish,
this is what the zebra
fish does when it thinks,
I mean what do you do when
you go to bed at night
and you're sitting there right.
There's no sensory input
coming, you're not moving,
but thoughts go through your head right?
I mean so that's gotta
be represented somewhere,
so this is getting tools
and techniques that allow us
to decode what those patterns are,
it's really the challenge.
And we're very fortunate
that tools and techniques
are coming online exactly
when we needed them.
It's called machine learning,
and there's a meeting that's
been held for the last 30 years
called Neural Information
Processing Systems, NIPS,
and the next meeting will be
held in Barcelona next week.
6,000 people will show up.
At the first meeting there was 600,
so it's a factor of 10 greater,
and every single high
tech company is showing up
to recruit and why, it turns out that
these tools and techniques
that have been developed
and have been inspired by
the brain, the N is neural,
turns out have fantastic
applications to the real world,
you've heard about deep learning,
well deep learning came
from this NIPS community.
And those same tools and
techniques can be used
for understanding those
patterns of activity
that you just saw for analyzing,
large scale recordings,
for working out the
detailed wiring diagram
called connectomics, and
for quantifying behavior.
Turns out that we can
go way beyond the simple
having an animal press a button
with having it move around freely.
And this can be done
automatically and scored
and it's been done on flies,
it's been done on mice,
they have a sequence
of stereotype behavior,
they groom themselves and so forth,
and interestingly on humans.
We can now detect and automatically score
your facial expressions.
Like we saw some pictures
of the fearful face,
well we've worked with Paul Eckman
and we've developed
these deep learning tools
to actually be able to
do that automatically
and we can detect these
fleeting moments of expression
across your face, they're
called micro-expressions.
And they're very telling
because they're brain leaks,
they're feelings you're having
inside that leak through
and you may not even be
aware of them yourself,
but they can be picked up now.
And that could be a way
that we can understand
a little bit more about the
internal state of your brain.
Okay so I just wanna end by saying that
Lyle Muller who was responsible
for doing that beautiful
rotating traveling wave
is out on the job market
so if you have a job for a
budding young experimentalist,
and a theoretician and a
data analyst, he's your man.
Thank you.
(applauding)
(cheerful music)